more than 60 metro police employees were  recognized for their bravery and  dedication it was a special ceremony  held on metro headquarters  63 employees commended for all of their  excellent work and heroic service  metro's employees shared some of their  stories including life-saving actions  from  police officers to situations where law  enforcement agents are put in harm's way  clark county sheriff joe lombardo says  it is important for the community  to know what kind of dangers and  situations our officers and civil  employees  face while working on metro's force  it's across the board recognitions that  we do as an agency  and it's i'm very proud it gives me the  opportunity to say hi  and say thank you just like the family  members would  and the opportunity for you to let the  public know  what we do on a daily basis all of the  officers and civilians received awards  for their community service exemplary  service life-saving and meritorious  service as well  up